we hear the words valid and validity
used all the time but I want to talk
about what validity means in a technical
sense with regard to something we've
already discussed deductive arguments as
a reminder a deductive argument is an
argument where the premises logically
guaranteed the conclusion for example if
a is B and B is C a must be C there is
no alternative the concept of validity
is a tool for evaluating the internal
logic of a deductive argument to say
that an argument is valid is not the
same as saying that the argument is good
or sound for example imagine the premise
that all dogs can fly and the second
premise that Fido is a dog the
conclusion would be that Fido can fly
although it might seem counterintuitive
this is a valid argument an argument is
valid if the truth of the premises would
guarantee the truth of the conclusion if
it is true that all dogs can fly then it
must be true that Fido the dog can fly
but let's put this argument under more
scrutiny this is a valid argument but it
is not a sound argument soundness is an
evaluation of both whether an argument
is valid and whether its premises are
true a sound argument must be both valid
and have true premises not all dogs can
fly so one of the premises is false and
our argument is not sound so validity
and soundness are properties of an
argument and truth is a property of a
statement here's an argument that is
sound because it is both valid and has
true premises all US senators are
politicians Ted Cruz is a US senator the
conclusion is that Ted Cruz is a
politician it's a horrible reality but
it is a reality and it is a sound
argument here's an argument where the
premises are true but the argument is
invalid so the argument is not sound
Paris is a city Germany is a country
conclusion Paris is the capital of
Germany it's not sound because that
conclusion is not guaranteed
by the truth of the premises but what
about this one Marco Rubio is a
Republican which is true Hillary Clinton
is a Democrat which is true and the
conclusion is that Jill Stein is a
member of the Green Party in this
particular case both of the premises are
true and the conclusion happens to be
true but the two premises don't
logically guarantee that conclusion so
the argument is invalid and therefore it
is not sound we should only accept
conclusions of arguments that are both
valid and sound if you're interested in
philosophy and critical thinking you
will love brilliant which has pretty
much become my go-to for learning things
online check out brilliance new
immersive lessons on logic
problem-solving multi level thinking
identifying false information and
identifying fallacies whether you
already have a grasp on any of these
subjects or you're looking for a fun and
engaging way to become acquainted with
these topics for the first time
brilliant really is the place to go
where you can actually learn hands-on by
solving problems and puzzles designed by
expert educators and unlike other
learning sites when I'm using brilliant
I'm actually learning by working
hands-on with real-world scenarios and
problems sign up for free by going to
brilliant org slash critical thinking
I've put a link in the description under
this video and the first 200 people who
visit will get 20% off an annual Premium
Membership visit brilliant org slash
critical thinking